pour ces élections départementales
europe ecologie les verts yvelines a
choisi sa stratégie les huit groupes
locaux on remontait à l'instance
départementale leurs souhaits pour les
différents cantons afin d'adapter leur
candidature on n'a pas opté pour avoir
une stratégie départementale comme
certains départements comme le 93
on a opté pour avoir une stratégie vous
variable en fonction des configurations
donc il ya six cantons qui partent en
autonomie europe ecologie les verts sans
autre partenaire
on a des cantons qui partent avec
uniquement génération s c'est à dire des
contes des élections qui sont sur ce
qu'on appelle le pôle écolo d'autres
candidats partent avec le parti
communiste où le parti socialiste
certains ont également formé une
alliance de la gauche exemple à trappes
ou élever cet allié aux cinq autres
partis de la gauche génération s
le parti communiste français la france
insoumise le parti socialiste et
nouvelle donne à mon sens est essentiel
d'avoir une alliance parce que ça montre
je dirais le travail en commun et la
même volonté et quand on a ces mêmes
idées ces mêmes valeurs mais il faut les
porter ensemble plus que de vouloir
opposer les candidatures et diviser les
électeurs des discussions avec les
autres partis qui n'ont pas toujours
abouties mais pour tous les cantons
l'objectif reste le même avoir un
maximum de candidats élus notre objectif
c'est d'en avoir plusieurs et localement
chacun a estimé que c'était il avait
choisi la meilleure stratégie possible
après il ya eu des négociations
départementale au niveau des partis de
gauche et des partis écologistes les
négociations était un peu tendu mais
elles se sont faites et chacun a accepté
la démarche que europe ecologie les
verts du département avait choisi une
tactique départemental en partie
décidées pour faire face à la droite qui
avait remporté tous les cantons lors des
précédentes élections en 2015